c'était le palais privé d'un ancien
président cubain a construit vers 1915
une adresse prestigieuse sur la
promenade du pradeau
il a failli être transformé en un
stationnement mais la révolution la
sauver le gouvernement cubain a restauré
le palais à grands frais et on peut y
admirer ses marbres et ses vitraux son
escalier grandiose
ces salons sur l'atrium vitré ce palais
non seulement tu vas la restaurer mais
il a donné oui cadeau à l'alliance
française qui en a fait son quartier
général
inauguré par le président françois
hollande en visite officielle en 2015
pourquoi cette générosité parce que
lille a gardé un petit faible pour cette
institution vieille de cent trente cinq
ans dédié au rayonnement de la langue et
la culture française dans le monde
che guevara y est pour beaucoup il y a
appris le français dans sa jeunesse en
argentine qui m'a dit ou de ce guide to
l'industrie tout la technique et tout la
technologie depa
des états unis et des usines des états
unis et changer tout ça c'est une chose
assez difficile à la révolution
l'alliance est nationalisé mais lotscher
s'oppose à sa disparition
ce que confirme le président du conseil
d'administration de l'alliance rica dr
john wayne
je vais même temps dire plus couanau la
lola-aer hier encore attendre la seroma
pendant la lutte de la guérilla cubaine
dans la sierra maestra le che avait avec
lui ses livres de l'alliance française
il pratiquait le français dans la sierra
et et raul castro notre président actuel
s'est mis à étudier le français avec le
che comme professeur en utilisant les
livres de l'alliance française
d'ailleurs dans son journal le che parle
de la qualité des livres de l'alliance
un gros joueur aime jouer à deux elle
commente pas la qualité
d'où cette autre révélation alors raul
castro par le français bien leurs bases
et qu'est ce qui se passe c'est qu'il ne
le pratique pas beaucoup faute de
possibilités mais il le parle
bien vu
[Musique]
raul castro n'est pas le seul plus de
4000 cubain viennent à l'alliance pour y
apprendre le français
un record mondial ils le font pour
toutes sortes de raisons parce que j'y
travaille à un accord l'un des dix
auteurs des vols étudié depuis longtemps
et deux ans parce que je suis étudiant à
l'université pédagogique pour
naisseur des anglais aussi il y a trois
succursales de l'alliance à la havane et
une à santiago
il n'y a pas que les cours de langue il
faut y ajouter les activités culturelles
semaine du ciné ou de la francophonie
jeux et chansons pour enfants qui sont
organisées comment expliquer cet
engouement
d'abord il n'ya pas de passé colonial
français mais aussi par une forte
présence culturelle française
littérature peinture science et même
musique
ils y ont trouvé un terrain fertile
d'etreham ans et je dirais même que les
gens qui veulent acquérir une certaine
culture et je parle de gens de classe
moyenne et même du prolétariat ont pour
objectif d'apprendre le français et à
cuba c'est quelque chose de sentimental
conclut ricardo torres scène du mann
talent qui parle autant au coeur car la
raison
jean michel le bras droit du canada la
havane
[Musique]